ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five four
three
two
one ghost writer be on the page
hi
here we are ready to go for episode 4 of
ghost writer beyond the page so far
donna has gotten lots of very helpful
hints from ghost rider to help her
create her story she's come up with the
wichita character unique settings and
some key plot points it's time for her
to put it all together for the first
time her story is going to come to life
it's alive
not that much different from the the
challenge that the doctor faced in
frankenstein as he has to deal with his
creation
so let's see how donna deals with her
creation as she works to finish her book
let's see
welcome to donna's video diary
sapphire's adventure is really coming
together
to try to get her friends to see her
talent for sewing and fashion the same
way that they appreciate her brother's
athletics sapphire decides what better
way to show off her work than with a
fashion show perfect right
but that's when the obstacles come in to
create more conflict
spellman has a soccer game scheduled at
the exact same time as sapphire's show
and their friends have to decide which
one to go to
plus two of sapphire's models are on the
soccer team so she has to come up with a
solution fast
and on top of all of that the humans
sweep out the entire fashion section of
the store destroying all of sapphire's
designs
so much drama i'm loving this
don't worry though in the end spelman
sees sapphire's new designs and is
really impressed
he tells his sister and with spelman on
her side she spins up a whole new plan
she convinces the coach to let her put
on the show in half time right in the
middle of the field
it's a totally fashion forward
spectacular halftime show and spellman
even volunteers to be one of the models
the crowd goes wild
sapphire's designs are a showstopper
they're the talk of the bookstore bugs
they even want her to design the new
uniforms for the team her hard work and
creativity really pay off
you know
it feels like i practically just started
and now i almost have all the pieces
ready to actually put together my story
i
almost don't want to reach the finish
line
it's like reaching the final chapter of
a book i never want to end
well
ghostwriter hasn't sent anything new yet
so maybe i should just focus more on the
pieces that i already have
i could spend more time creating some
more characters or get more detailed
with the setting before i just dive
right into actually writing them into
the story
create
create on every page
ghostwriter is really trying to make a
point with this one
it's not hard to see that gw wants me to
get writing and finish creating my story
there's got to be another step first
right
i mean
what about coming up with more bullet
points
i just i'm not ready to finish and
create
donna why what a wonderful surprise
it's nice to see you too dr frankenstein
your visit is well timed i'm just
finishing packing up some things i'm
traveling soon oh well i'm glad i didn't
um miss you
actually i was wondering if i could ask
you something of course i'm happy to
offer any insight i can well you see
i've started this project and i'm really
close to finishing it i've got all the
pieces ready and i just need to put them
together
but
i'm not sure if i feel ready for it to
come to an end
i mean you wish you had waited and
really thought things through before you
put together bob or i mean the monster
well the truth is at first i did wish i
had not been so eager to finish creating
my monster oh
well
what do you wish now
what i truly wish looking back is that
i'd followed through with my experiment
to the very end
that i taught him skills and compassion
and shown him love if i had seen my
experiment through then
when he went out into the world
he could have had a truly good life
well that's not exactly the answer i was
expecting
but i know you must be right
bob did have a lot of potential to be
good
if only he was given a chance
exactly
donna
i know sometimes we can get in our own
way as we approach the final moments of
things we don't want to end
but
i do hope that you follow through and
finish your project who can say what
wonders you may be able to create if you
never finish them you're right dr
frankenstein
i might never feel ready to come to the
end of this journey and see what comes
next
but i won't know until i cross the
finish line
thanks for all your help
it has been a pleasure seeing you again
donna and i anticipate great things from
you and your project
dr frankenstein is right i'll never get
to see where my story could go if i
never take the final step
hey i bet there's a good chapter in
frankenstein to help me out
my story is long and you must be cold
the monster said
he invited me to sit and pulled branches
off a nearby tree to start a small fire
i hardly remember the night i came to
life he said
people on the street screamed when they
saw me some tried to attack many threw
things at me i quickly learned to hide
my face and avoid humans
then i got hungry
i found food in a shop window
the glass was easy to break
i didn't know why angry voices chased me
i ran far away from the city and into
the forest
finally i came to a cottage with a small
woodshed
i curled up to sleep behind a pile of
firewood i awoke to voices the creature
continued it was morning
the family who lived in the cottage was
waking up i wanted to run away but i
heard them speaking
their voices were cheerful and pleasant
they sounded completely different from
all the angry voices i had heard in my
short life
what did the family do when they saw you
i asked
they didn't i stayed out of sight the
monster nodded
the cottage was home to a very old man
and his teenage grandson and
granddaughter
they were a poor but loving family
i stole food from their garden and slept
in their woodshed without being caught
i lived this way for weeks the monster
said
until i started to notice how the family
always did things for each other
they made each other happier by helping
and when they were happy it made me
happy
so in secret i did chores to help them
i only did small things
i refilled their woodshed and kept wild
animals away from their house and garden
i tried to make their lives easier
without having them realize i was there
i was glad to hear that the monster had
done a good deed
my heart twinged with a strange feeling
was it pride
if dr frankenstein had just helped the
monster and followed through instead of
avoiding him the monster could have had
a better life and maybe even taught the
doctor something new along the way
i'm ready for what comes next
in fact
i'm really excited
i know that i have to finish creating
this adventure to start the new one and
hey maybe i'll even share my story with
my friends and family when it's done
when one chapter ends the next one
begins
now if you want to dive deeper into the
ghostwriter world be sure to read
frankenstein and go to the franken ghost
section of the activity guide and of
course check in with the ghostwriter
gang on apple tv plus to watch episodes
of the show so until we meet again
keep on writing keep on creating and
keep on sharing bye now
you